merci d'être avec nous uniquement et
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénatrice socialiste des
Landes vice-président de la commission
des affaires sociales vous êtes membre
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
et chef de fil du groupe socialiste sur
la réforme des retraites dont on va
longuement parler évidemment mais
d'abord une question sur un autre sujet
puisqu'on est en plein salon de
l'agriculture et qui reçoit à minuit se
sont achevés les négociations entre les
producteurs et les industriels de
l'agroalimentaire elles ont été tendues
cette année en région de l'inflation de
la hausse du coût de l'énergie alors les
lois également amélioré les revenus des
agriculteurs mais vous qui êtes dans des
dans un département qui compte de
nombreux agriculteurs est-ce que c'est
suffisant quel est le ressenti des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui
les lois et gallimes elles ont elles ont
amélioré en tout cas elles étaient
faites pour améliorer mais quelquefois
ça n'est pas le cas moi j'ai discuté il
y a quelques mois avec responsable d'une
entreprise d'agroalimentaire qui
transforme notamment du foie gras et qui
m'expliquait que du foie gras et et des
produits dérivés du canard et qui
expliqué que on fait les lois égalines
elle elle lui posait problème parce que
justement certains produits dans cette
filière là en tout cas ne se vend de
qu'en promotion et la loi egalim
interdit un certain nombre de promotions
en fait on a l'impression que c'est sans
fin c'est à dire que on produit une loi
on fait une loi qui qui a pour vocation
que les agriculteurs soient mieux
rémunérés mais on a l'impression que la
grande distribution se débrouille
toujours à trouver des solutions pour ne
pas rémunérer pour que les pour qu'au
bout de la chaîne ou plutôt au début de
la chaîne les producteurs soient mal
rétribués de leur travail donc en fait
j'ai l'impression
qu'il faut faire plus d'efforts bien sûr
que la la grande distribution on le sait
gagne beaucoup beaucoup d'argent les
producteurs sont mal payés et les
salariés de la grande distribution sont
mal payés
coup d'envoi de la réforme des retraites
on va évidemment longuement parler
aujourd'hui à 14h30 dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat vous et vos collègues de gauche
comptez bien imprimer votre marque sur
ce texte on va en parler avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Samia de chien
[Musique]
bonjour Samia bonjour Oriane bonjour
Monique cubain bonjour et Samia la
gauche sénatoriale a dévoilé hier une
position commune sur la réforme des
retraites Samia vous avez suivi cette
conférence de presse oui vous étiez
Monique Lubin il y avait les
représentants des trois groupes
politiques de gauche au Sénat les
socialistes les communistes et les
écologistes alors je rappelle quand même
que la nuque n'existe pas au Sénat il
n'y a pas d'interview de gauche comme à
l'Assemblée nationale mais cela
n'empêche pas des alliances entre ces
trois groupes sur certains textes et
c'est le cas sur cette réforme des
retraites la gauche affiche son unité
unité dans le rejet de la réforme
écoutée Patrick canard
nous voulons faire front déterminer
contre cette réforme que nous qualifions
de réformes de régression sociale nous
allons nous battre
pas échappé que nous étions minoritaire
au sein du Sénat mais nous serons une
opposition
déterminée nous battre contre cette
réforme qui traduit finalement
l'entêtement d'un gouvernement et aussi
l'endettement du président de la
République à faire passer en force
contre manifestement une très grande
majorité des Français une réforme que
nous qualifions d'injuste alors la
gauche va donc se battre au Sénat mais
pas tout à fait avec la même stratégie
qu'elle l'Assemblée nationale ou la
nuque a déposée 18000 amendements ça a
tellement ralenti les débats que
l'examen c'était arrêté après l'article
2 alors que le texte en compte 20 au
Sénat il n'y a que
4727 amendements il n'y aura donc pas de
stratégie d'obstruction du moins pas
tout de suite parce que la gauche veut
aller au moins jusqu'à l'examen de
l'article 7 l'article 7 c'est vraiment
le coeur de la réforme celui qui prévoit
de reporter l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ans donc cette fois au
Sénat la gauche veut bien en vote mais
pas à n'importe quel moment alors elle a
passé un accord de calendrier avec le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher
on est une gauche puisque c'est un mot à
la mode responsable
nous sommes des hommes et des femmes
politiques responsables donc ce matin
nous avons effectivement lors de la
réunion des présidents de groupe posé
la question de l'article 7 et que nous
souhaitions vivement qu'il y ait donc je
le répète un débat sur l'article 7 et un
vote sur l'article 7 après la
mobilisation du 7 du 7 mars ça peut être
dans la nuit du 7 au 8 le 8 le 9 on sait
pas mais voilà ça c'est me semble-t-il
acté alors voter l'article clé de la
réforme après la grande journée de
mobilisation du 7 mars est-ce que vous
espérez réellement uniquement que ça
peut vraiment changer le cours des
débats au Sénat d'une façon ou d'une
autre
ce n'est pas forcément alors d'abord
c'est une marque de soutien au mouvement
syndical et au mouvement populaire qui
va s'exprimer dans la rue et puis il est
quand même évident que si la
mobilisation est très très forte ce que
nous espérons et ce que je crois à titre
personnel il est évident que les débats
au Sénat peuvent prendre une autre
teneur peuvent sur ce sujet là sur le
sur le sujet du report de l'âge de la
retraite vous savez que les
manifestations portent sur ce sujet là
non à la retraite à 64 ans l'article 7
ne parlera que de ce sujet là donc il
est évident que
discuter de cet article 7 au moment où
après la mobilisation peut donner
effectivement une
une autre teneur et pour vous espérez
que le dessinateur qui change d'avis au
vu de la mobilisation écoutez moi je ne
désespère pas nous savons qu'un certain
nombre de sénateurs nous savons qu'un
certain nombre de de
d'adhérents des républicains ne sont pas
d'accord avec cette réforme chez les
députés nous l'avons vu chez les
Sénateurs pour l'instant nous
n'entendons pas grand chose mais mais
sans plus unis ils sont plus unis mais
une petite musique
comme ça individuellement vous en
croisez quand même certains qui vous
disent
ça coince pour les suites des débages
justement après l'article 7 la position
de votre groupe et de la gauche en
général au Sénat n'est pas très clair
vous avez dit hier on souhaite examiner
comme le plus possible de mesures après
l'article 7 et en même temps vous avez
dit on assume qu'on ne veut pas aller au
bout alors finalement est-ce que vous
ferez obstruction comme vos collègues de
l'Assemblée ou pas alors comme nos
collègues faire obstruction comme nos
collègues de l'Assemblée non clairement
nous ce que nous voulons c'est la
discussion de tous les articles parce
qu'on parle de l'article 7 qui est le
plus important mais sur les articles
derrière il y a aussi des choses
importantes les fameux 1200 euros il y a
des mesures pour le la retraite des
aidants il y a des choses donc nous nous
voulons vraiment discuter jusqu'au bout
mais discuter jusqu'au bout sans obtenir
un vote final ça paraît possible donc
vous ne souhaitez pas de votre final sur
l'ensemble du texte
nous nous estimons qu'une une
[Musique]
le lendemain le président Larcher le
répète le droit d'amendement c'est le
droit inhérent au débat parlementaire et
nous comptons l'utiliser pleinement
alors après faire obstruction c'est dire
n'importe quoi parler de n'importe quoi
lorsqu'on présente un amendement
c'est-à-dire d'un sujet qui n'a rien à
voir avec le sujet qui est traité dans
le projet de loi ça nous le ferons pas
et le président l'archet verra que si
nous avons déposé beaucoup d'amendements
il tourne tous autour du sujet donc nous
espérons sincèrement que le président du
Sénat ne déploiera pas certains
artifices qui sont prévus dans le
règlement du Sénat qui permettrait de
nous finalement
et de nous couper la parole en quelque
sorte
artifice qui si j'ai bien compris existe
mais n'ont jamais été utilisés ce serait
quand même un comble il y a un moment où
le gouvernement a choisi un véhicule
législatif pour faire en sorte le
véhicule législatif qui fait que on peut
discuter le moins longtemps possible il
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale ce serait quand
même assez cocasse que le président du
Sénat qui n'arrête pas de répéter que
nous sommes une chambre responsable et
il a raison ne permette pas que ce débat
se déroule jusqu'au bout ça vient sur le
fond du coup du texte oui il y a des
modifications qui ont été apportées on
le sait par la droite sénatoriale ou
plutôt la majorité de droitiers du
centre par exemple sur la retraite des
femmes ayant eu au moins un enfant il
propose une surcote de 5% est-ce que la
gauche pourrait voter cette mesure non
non nous ne voterons pas cette mesure
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que les
femmes qui arrivent à 62 ans 63 ans
qui ont tout la trimestre qui pourrait
prendre leur retraite ne demande pas à
avoir 5% de pension de plus elle demande
à ne pas travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
premièrement deuxièmement aujourd'hui
une femme qui arrive à la retraite à 62
ans qui arrive à 62 ans avec tous ces
trimestres qui peut faire valoir ses
droits à la retraite mais qui décide de
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans peu bénéficier
d'une surcote de 10%
demain avec cette mesure elle sera
obligée de travailler jusqu'à 64 ans et
au final à condition qu'elle ait des
droits familiaux c'est à dire qu'elle
ait eu des enfants elle n'aura plus que
5% de surcote c'est quand même c'est pas
une amélioration par rapport aux taxes
initial du gouvernement est-ce qu'on ne
votant pas cette mesure vous n'empêchez
pas une avancée pour les femmes par
rapport au Texas l'avancée pour les
femmes ça serait le retrait de cette de
cette réforme nous n'allons pas
tergiverser
la droite la majorité sénatoriale
propose des mesures qui sont faites pour
adoucir ce texte de loi qui est
extrêmement brutal pour un grand nombre
de Français nous-mêmes nous-mêmes allons
proposer des amendements ça peut vous
paraître paradoxal mais justement pour
démontrer que ce texte de loi est
brutale et qu'il ne peut pas être
appliqué mais la différence entre la
majorité sénatoriale et nous c'est que
eux sont d'accord sur le report de l'âge
de la retraite et nous nous y sommes
absolument opposés sur les femmes par
exemple qu'est-ce que vous allez déposer
vous comme amendement alors sur les
femmes et bien moi je je vais proposer
qu'à 62 ans les femmes qui bénéficient
de droits familiaux c'est-à-dire les la
bonification de 8 trimestres par enfant
puisse partir puisse prendre leur
retraite à 62 ans si elles ont ses
droits familiaux et si elles ont le
nombre de trimestres requis à 62 ans je
vais
pas perdre en fait voilà les trimestres
maternité vont être perdus je veux dire
les femmes sont pendant toute leur
carrière et toute leur vie
sont
bénéficient de beaucoup moins davantage
on le sait sont pénalisés du fait
justement notamment de la maternité sont
durement pénalisés sur leur carrière
elles ont un avantage qui est de 8
trimestres par enfant et finalement
cette réforme va en enlever les
bénéfices pour une grande partie d'entre
elles
autre mesure à introduite par la
majorité sénatorielle c'est la création
d'un CDI senior est-ce que ça vous y
êtes favorable alors ça c'est un petit
peu plus difficile de répondre de
manière aussi claire moi j'ai travaillé
avec le sénateur René Paul Savary nous
avons fait ensemble tout un travail et
sortir un rapport sur l'emploi des
seniors nous savons que dans ce pays il
y a une espèce de de culture qui fait
que les employeurs ne sont plus
intéressés par des des salariés qui ont
on va dire plus de 50 ans
et donc
finalement est-ce qu'il faut des mesures
coercitives est-ce qu'il faut des
mesures incitatives c'est très compliqué
je j'aurais tendance à dire qu'on
pourrait expérimenter des formes de de
contrats spécifiques au seniors mais
alors par contre je suis tout allemand
opposée à tout ce qui est
exonération de cotisations
sociales oui parce que pour rappel le
CDI senior que propose la majorité
sénatoriales c'est un contrat qui serait
exonéré de cotisation famille en échange
l'embauche d'un senior qui pourrait par
exemple faire du tutorat donc sur ce CDI
Seigneur là vous votre écran est-ce que
vous avez une autre proposition alors de
la gauche sanatoriale moi par exemple
nous par exemple nous allons proposer
que dans les entreprises entreprises de
plus de 300 salariés
il y est toujours un pourcentage de 15%
de seniors on va proposer aussi
d'ailleurs dans lever le terme Seigneur
ce qui est particulièrement discriminant
on va dire personne de plus de 50 ans
alors 15% ça peut paraître mais
difficile à tenir peut-être sur le on
fait ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
on ne se débarrasse pas des gens qui ont
plus de 50 ans ou plus de 55 ans et que
quand on recrute on ne ferme pas la
porte automatiquement à toutes les
candidatures de personnes qui ont plus
de 50 ans c'est une idée d'un autre
sujet qui fait débat et qui n'a pas été
tranché en commission d'ailleurs c'est
la question des carrières longues quels
seront vos propositions sur le sujet
est-ce que vous souhaitez que tous les
Français dans un dispositif carrière
longue ne travaillent pas plus de 43 ans
oui la première ministre je vais même
au-delà des carrières longues la
première ministre a dit personne ne doit
travailler plus de 43 ans dont nous lui
disons
banco allons-y c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui a commencé à
travailler à 18 ans qui donc dans ce
projet de réforme devrait travailler
jusqu'à 62 ans ça fait 44 ans donc nous
disons non pas plus de 43 ans donc qui
s'arrête à 61 ans c'est ce qu'elle a
promis on ne sait pas trop sous quelle
forme encore mais moi je vais au-delà
quelqu'un qui a commencé à travailler à
20 ans
qui n'est donc pas carrière longue mais
qui travaille jusqu'à 63 ans ça fait 43
ans qu'il puisse partir à la retraite
donc c'est-à-dire on met plus d'âge
légal de départ pour vous la seule chose
qui compte et bien justement ce que je
veux amener comme débat c'est que là
nous ne sommes pas dans un projet de
Loire retraite parce que si nous étions
dans un projet de loi retraite nous
pourrions discuter de tout cela et y
compris âge légal page légale uniquement
les annuités là on n'est pas là-dedans
donc je sais très bien que mon
amendement n'a aucune chance d'aboutir
peut-être même sera-t-il dans notre
jargon article 40 c'est à dire que on
pourra peut-être moins pas en débattre
mais je trouverai une façon dans
l'hémicycle bien évidemment dans des
battre mais mais mais si nous avions un
véritable projet de loi retraite nous
pourrions parler de toutes ces choses là
de celle là et d'autres encore financier
bien sûr sur justement puisque on parle
des finances hier on a entendu Patrick
Kanner dénoncé que le fait que cette
réforme est bricolé et qu'à force de
concession ce ne sont plus les 17
milliards annoncés mais on est plutôt
entre 10 et 12 milliards de rendements
financiers comme il a dit reprenant les
propos de d'Élisabeth borde on sait que
la droite sénatoriale veut insister
là-dessus et rechercher des économies
vous comprenez cette démarche est-ce que
vous allez la soutenir là non non non
nous n'allons pas soutenir cette
démarche mais je trouve que ce qui est
intéressant dans cette démonstration
c'est que justement on voit que les
républicains la majorité est obligée de
proposer des amendements qui viennent
adoucir comme j'ai déjà dit la brutalité
de cette réforme que ce qu'il propose à
un coût et que finalement si le
gouvernement accepte
ses amendements et bien sa volonté
première qui est de faire des économies
ne sera pas respecté on voit bien en
fait la boucle se former et au final ce
que nous disons tout simplement cette
loi est mal faite elle est mal ficelée
c'est du bricolage depuis le début il
faut la retirer toujours sur l'aspect
financier les commissions des finances
du Sénat c'est prononcée disant que
l'équilibre du système des retraites
n'était finalement pas garanti par la
réforme du fait de toutes les
modifications qui ont été apportées à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que c'est
un argument que vous allez porter dans
l'hémicycle dans cette séance qui
s'ouvre cet après-midi pour pousser au
retrait de la réforme finalement
l'objectif ne sera pas atteint oui bien
sûr je risque de répéter ce que ce que
je viens de dire on voit bien justement
qu'au sortir du Sénat si cette réforme
est votée avec ce que va amener la
majorité
sénatoriale le l'équilibre voulu par le
gouvernement par le pas de l'équilibre
général des systèmes de retraite
l'équilibre voulu par le gouvernement ne
sera pas au rendez-vous et donc ça ne
servira à rien et le risque au final
c'est que
dans cinq ans même avant on nous dise il
faut une autre réforme et là qu'est-ce
qu'on nous dira qu'il faut encore
reculer l'âge
de des parts à la retraite on fait moi
la question que je voulais véritable le
fait qu'il y a une autre réforme à court
terme alors
il faut bien reprendre les choses dès le
départ actuellement et contrairement à
ce que j'entends j'ai entendu notamment
monsieur Véran hier qui a dit n'importe
quoi une fois de plus vraiment et et qui
essaie d'affoler dans les campagnes pour
que tout d'un coup tout le monde soit
favorable à cette réforme actuellement
le système nos systèmes de retraite ne
sont pas en déficit actuellement il faut
le dire
actuellement mais ce sera pas le faire
il y a des projections qui vont jusqu'à
12 13 milliards je rappelle qu'il y a
trois ans au sortir en plein cœur du
covid les projections elles étaient de
30 milliards de déficit pour 2000 pour
2022 2021-2022 vous voyez qu'on on est
même légèrement excédentaire donc il
faut arrêter ce que je pense c'est que
il y a effectivement des choses qui se
profilent à l'horizon et c'est notamment
la baisse des retraites la baisse des
revenus des futurs retraités par rapport
aux revenus des actifs voilà il faut
travailler à ça il faut travailler à ça
et donc il faut une réforme à mon avis
il faudrait que nous ayons une véritable
réforme des retraites mais
pas dans le but
d'amener les gens à travailler plus dans
le but à trouver de nouvelles recettes
le président du corps l'a dit ça n'est
pas un problème de dépenses c'est un
problème de recette alors et de garantie
du niveau de vie de retraite alors vous
me direz quand il y a un problème de
recettes il y a forcément un déficit
mais ce qu'il a voulu dire c'est que
nous n'avons pas d'inquiétude sur la
trajectoire des dépenses il faut trouver
des recettes est-ce que les seules
recettes peuvent se trouver dans le
report de l'âge de la retraite moi j'ai
une question à poser je sais qu'à quel
âge jusqu'à quel âge peut-on faire
travailler les français et notamment
tous ces Français qui se lèvent tôt et
qui ont les métiers les plus pénibles
c'est une véritable question nous
semble-t-il et que vous poserez on n'en
doute pas dans l'hémicycle début des
débats à 14h30 évidemment ce sera à
suivre en direct sur notre antenne on en
parle tout à l'heure Samia avec vous
avec plaisir dans le club on va faire un
petit détour par votre département
maintenant manuclubin on va voir
l'actualité dans les Landes avec
Jefferson des sports de Sud-Ouest
bonjour Jefferson merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous de Jefferson vous avez deux
questions pour Monique Lubin on commence
avec une première question sur la
sécheresse
oui
que les retraites donc Monique cubain
plusieurs départements déjà pris des
mesures de restriction d'eau le 21
février à Mont-de-Marsan les
agriculteurs ont manifesté pour défendre
leurs droits à l'irrigation est-ce que
vous les soutenez ou est-ce que vous
appelez à des mesures de restriction
sans attendre
c'est très difficile de répondre à cette
question je pourrais je pourrais être je
pourrais être complètement démago et
vous dire oui je les soutiens il faut
absolument
notre agriculture a besoin d'eau donc
oui quelque part je soutiens les
agriculteurs mais je suis quand même
très inquiète de cette question du
partage de l'eau qui se pose de manière
particulièrement accrue cette année dans
les Landes je de souvenir de landaise
de longue date
de toujours je n'ai pas connu ce genre
de période je n'ai pas connu un moment
où il fallait qu'on tranche entre
utilisation de l'eau pour tout le monde
et utilisation pour les agriculteurs on
arrivait à partager même si les
agriculteurs trouvent que c'est parfois
insuffisant mais on arrivait clairement
à partager sans qu'il y ait de conflits
d'usage bon là je que je souhaiterais
quand même c'est que
le pire n'étant jamais certains c'est
que cette année les autorisations
restent stables et on verra ensuite j'ai
envie de dire en fonction de ce qui
tombe du ciel mais quand je dis ça je
sais aussi que je ne suis pas très
raisonnable je suis inquiète et je
franchement je vous donnerai pas de
réponse d'emmago
et simpliste Jefferson il y a une autre
question qui est un peu liée un question
sur les incendies cette fois
complètement Monique luber ça va faire
le lien avec ce qu'on vient de dire
puisque cette sécheresse très précoce
fait craindre le retour des incendies
beaucoup plus tôt dans la saison on sait
que l'été dernier les langues comme la
Gironde ont été très durement impactés
est-ce que vous avez des assurances que
les moyens aériens qui sont attendus
dans le Sud-Ouest le seront bien
positionnés dans le Sud-Ouest avant cet
été c'est-à-dire des Canadairs notamment
je ne à ce stade là moi je ne sais pas
je n'ai pas la réponse à cette question
je sais que le président du conseil
départemental des Landes mais et celui
de la Gironde Gironde qui a été quand
même bien plus impacté que les Landes
même si les landes de nous l'avons été
beaucoup plus que les que les années
précédentes je sais que c'est ce que
nous demandons je ne pense pas que nous
ayons eu pour l'instant de garantie sur
ce sujet là
merci Jefferson merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous on regarde la Une de
Sud-Ouest ils sont jeunes et rêve
d'agriculture c'est à la Une de
Sud-Ouest aujourd'hui et merci beaucoup
Monique Lubin je vous avais été notre
invité bon débat puisque ça a commencé à
14h30 ce sera évidemment à suivre en
direct sur notre antenne on continue
notre émission spéciale réforme des
retraites dans 20 minutes des bas entre
deux sénateurs Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie pour les socialistes votre
collègue et Stéphane Le rugulier pour
les républicains mais d'abord on va
accueillir un président de groupe ici au
Sénat et François Patriat